[Musik]
jahrestag voller schmerz hanau trauert
um die opfer der rassistischen mord
serie vor einem jahr
corona zahlen mit vielen fragezeichen
die sorgen bei politik und experten
wachsen und schulterschluss mit europa
us-präsident beiden versuchte risse aus
der ära trump zu kippen und stellt
gleichzeitig bedingungen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers den abend hinein an
diesem freitagabend wir gucken natürlich
auch heute auf den sport nachher mit
kristin otto in 18 minuten und neun
morde in fünf minuten der anschlag von
hanau die rassistisch motivierte tat
eines 43 jährigen deutschen der danach
auch seine mutter und sich selbst
umbrachte genau ein jahr ist das her
das entsetzen über den hass auf
mitbürger mit ausländischen wurzeln der
aus dieser tat spricht ist bei vielen
immer noch da dieser tag heute steht im
zeichen des erinnerns und gedenkens an
die opfer
da wo sie ermordet wurden heute blumen
fotos kerzen und die botschaft ihr seid
nicht vergessen
drei von ihnen sind auf dem hanauer
hauptfriedhof begraben doch die trauer
gilt allen zusammen einer frau acht
männern der jüngste 21 der älteste 37
jahre alt es gibt noch viele fragen die
offen sind und nicht nur familien und
freunde quellen peter theißen ein jahr
nach dem rassistischen anschlag sind die
wunden noch lange nicht geheilt warum
mussten neun junge menschen starben
mitten in hanau mitten in deutschland
weil sie anders aussahen anderen namen
hatten sie waren hanauer wie wir so
sehen es diese schüler schweigeminute
für die opfer teilweise waren sie kaum
älter als sie selbst
und dass man sowas passiert wollen da wo
man eigentlich sich oft aufhält und ich
meine wetter am ende auch jeden von uns
treffen können
das leben ist sowieso schon schwer genug
und dass man sich stand auch noch mit
hass das leben noch schwerer macht das
muss man sich nicht antun
heute setzt hanau ein starkes zeichen
gegen hass vor allem aber gegen das
vergessen
sie sollen nicht umsonst gestorben sein
die botschaft des menschenfreundlichen
hanau
doch es gibt zweifel am
aufklärungswillen der behörden viele
fragen zur tat sind bis heute nicht
beantwortet
[Musik]
misstrauen mischt sich in die trauer der
hinterbliebenen
diese skepsis nimmt der bundespräsident
auf bei der zentralen
gedenkveranstaltung
lasst nicht zu dass die böse tat und
spaltet übersehen bin ich die bösen
geister in unserer mitte nicht den hass
die ausgrenzung die gleichgültigkeit
aber bitte lasst uns glauben an den
besseren geist unseres landes an die
kraft zum miteinander den willen zum
gemeinsamen wir
heute hat hanau dieses wir-gefühl
eindrucksvoll gezeigt ein zeichen
gesetzt gegen hass und rassismus
[Musik]
in und um hanau leuten jetzt zum ende
der gedenkfeiern alle glocken
das sind live-bilder und wir lassen sie
mal einen moment zu erstehen
[Musik]
und gucken jetzt auf das leid der
angehörigen der hinterbliebenen und ihre
fragen die es auch ein jahr danach immer
noch gibt der zentralrat der muslime in
deutschland wünscht sich heute das
stärker betont werden
das waren deutsche das waren unsere
landsleute die angegriffen wurden so
sanderson tina mit mehr willy viorel
paar wurde 22 jahre alt seine eltern
julia und niculescu sind immer noch tief
traurig ihr sohn willi lebte mit ihnen
zusammen bei ihr einziges kind und immer
noch immer noch drei monate nach der tat
hatten wir die beiden zum ersten mal
getroffen
sie zeigten uns damals das handy von
willi dass sie am vortag von der polizei
zurück bekommen hatten
willi hatte in der tatnacht versucht die
polizei zu erreichen
oben rechts ist willis auto zu sehen
tobias er rennt nach den ersten morgen
an ihm vorbei willi bemerkt ihn fährt
mit seinem auto zurück und nimmt die
verfolgung auf bis zum zweiten tatort
dort wird will in seinem auto von tobias
er erschossen
man hat tobias verfolgt hat viel marke
von hier zum polizei war und keine
antwort von polizei und das verstehen
das nicht
mittlerweile ist klar dass die polizei
hanau in der tatnacht unterbesetzt war
und das notrufsystem veraltet so dass
keine weiterleitung an eine zentrale
leitstelle möglich war
willi hat am tag der zivilcourage seine
eigene gedenkstätte bekommen auch die
angehörigen der anderen opfer zollen ihm
respekt seine eltern sind gerührt und
stolz aber ich brauch kein hemd wochen
bieten hause
die ließ eltern wollen klarheit warum
ihr sohn sterben musste ein jahr nach
dem rassistischen anschlag sind für die
angehörigen der neun jungen opfer noch
viele fragen offen
der bundespräsident hat heute gesagt es
bedrücke ihn sehr dass unser staat sein
versprechen von schutz sicherheit und
freiheit gegenüber den ermordeten nicht
habe einhalten können peter wagner ist
live für uns in hanau wir hören die
glocken immer noch peter guten abend was
sind denn die drängendsten punkte die
immer noch nicht geklärt sind in hanau
da sind ganz viele und vor acht monaten
war es hat bundesanwalt beck im
hessischen landtag den familien und den
überlebenden die antworten auf ihre
drängenden und quälenden fragen
versprochen aber es gibt ja noch immer
keinen abschlussbericht aus karlsruhe
zum beispiel welche rolle spielt der
vater des attentäters er jetzt mit
anzeigen die beseitigung der
gedenkstätten verlangt ist der
möglicherweise ein mittäter und warum
hat das notrufsystem teilweise versagt
wie so konnte ein seit jahren massiv
auffälliger mann wie der attentäter eine
waffenbesitzkarte erhalten warum wurde
seine wirre strafanzeige an den
generalbundesanwalt kurz vor der tat
nicht verfolgt und wieso wurde auch sein
rassistisches pamphlet auf seiner
webseite nicht vor der tat entdeckt
diese und viele weitere fragen stellen
sich und von einer schnellen antwort
darauf wird es abhängen ob die
angehörigen die überlebenden und auch
ganz hanau bald zur ruhe kommen können
mit der vagener vielen dank das ganze
jahr über hat unsere reporterin susanne
santana wir haben hier in filmen gerade
gesehen die menschen in hanau immer
wieder besucht ihre dokumentation auch
über die vielen offenen fragen finden
sie in der zdf mediathek und auf youtube
und damit zu unserem nächsten thema
heute abend in der sendung die korona
lage in deutschland und da gucken wir
zunächst mal auf die aktuellen zahlen
das robert-koch-institut verzeichnet
innerhalb eines tages 9113
neuinfektionen das sind rund 750 weniger
als vor einer woche
508 menschen starben in verbindung mit
cupid 19
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sinkt leicht auf jetzt 56,8 kein
wirklich eindeutiger trend also im
moment eine seitwärtsbewegung sagte der
gesundheitsminister
das robert koch institut warnt heute
nochmal die hoch ansteckenden mutationen
dürften den kampf gegen die pandemie
noch schwerer machen die regierung setzt
aufs impfen und mehr und mehr auch auf
schnelltests befürchtet aber auch da
engpässe florian hahn ein wort setzt bei
der korona lagebeschreibung in berlin
heute dem tun
man stehe möglicherweise erneut an einem
der punkt im kampf gegen das virus weil
die fallzahlen nicht mehr so wie zuletzt
sinken spielen hier eventuell die
besorgniserregenden varianten schon eine
rolle
meine damen und herren das wissen wir
noch nicht genau
aber was wir wissen ist dass sich die
variante b 11 7 in deutschland
ausbreitet eine variante die deutlich
ansteckender ist als das bisher
verbreitete virus was das für mögliche
lockerungen bedeutet dazu nur sehr
zurückhaltende antworten
wir müssen beim öffnen sehr behutsam und
umsichtig vorgehen um auch das erreichte
nicht zu verspielen
umso wichtiger dass die zahl der
impfungen steigt künftig könnten dabei
auch hausarztpraxen helfen
während der gesundheitsminister sich
noch nicht auf einen starttermin
festlegt rechnen ärztevertreter schon
mal vor wie groß der effekt sein könnte
wir haben mit sicherheit über 50.000
praxen impfen teilnehmen können das tun
sie nämlich jetzt auch schon mit anderen
impfungen und wenn sie rechnen dass nur
jede praxis am tag 20 menschen impfen
sind das pro woche fünf millionen
impfungen vorausgesetzt es gibt genügend
impfstoff was die sache erleichtern
könnte dass der impfstoff von bayern
texaner nach firmenangaben wohl doch
nicht so stark auf minus 60 bis 80 grad
gekühlt werden muss wie bisher
angenommen
entsprechende daten würden seit heute
von der us-arzneimittelbehörde geprüft
schließlich setzten auch die deutsche
politik verstärkt auf schnelltests ab
märz kostenlos für alle muss sparen mit
einer vorwarnung vorsieht
wie immer wenn etwas als kostenloses
angebot für alle startet wird es am
anfang wahrscheinlich auch schlangen
geben lokalen mal engpässe geben können
massenhafte schnell und selbsttests
könnten auch so die hoffnung ein
wendepunkt sein dann aber zum guten
so und jetzt in der sendung der blick
auf die weltpolitik die usa sind seit
heute offiziell zurück im pariser
klimaabkommen und zurück insgesamt mit
einer anderen politik als in den
vergangenen vier jahren pünktlich zum g
7 gipfel gastgeber großbritannien
begrüßte virtuell die staats und
regierungschefs
auch deutschland frankreich italien
japan kanada und den usa
wichtigstes thema die pandemie unter
anderem sagten die vereinigten staaten
deutschland und die eu weitere
finanzielle hilfen für die das impfen in
ärmeren ländern zu
und dann der auftritt des us-präsidenten
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
auf joe biden ruhen viele hoffnungen der
europäer aber es ist auch klar
automatisch einfacher wird es mit ihm
nicht stefan leifert münchen ist heute
dass es selten ist in einer woche der
sicherheitskonferenz eine ganz normale
stadt wo sich sonst die weltpolitik
tummelt und heute die lehre einer bühne
und doch vollzieht sich zwischen den
bildschirmen ein transatlantischer
zeitenwechsel amerika meldet sich zurück
in der weltgemeinschaft
ich sende die klare botschaft an die
welt amerika ist zurück die
transatlantische allianz ist zurück wir
schauen nicht nach hinten sondern
gemeinsam nach vorne joe biden lässt
keinen zweifel aufkommen die neue
transatlantische agenda soll mit ihm
wieder die alte werden usa und europa
gemeinsam vor allem im kampf der systeme
der wettbewerb mit china wird rauer
werden das erwarte ich und das begrüße
ich denn ich glaube an das globale
system das europa und amerika zusammen
mit ihren verbündeten in den letzten 70
jahren auch im pazifischen raum in so
harter arbeit aufgebaut haben in 15
minuten rede streichelt der neue
us-präsident die in vier jahren trump
geschunden europäische seele beschwört
gemeinsame werte und gemeinsam mit
gegner putin versucht das europäische
projekt und unsere nato allianz zu
schwächen
er will unsere transatlantische einheit
untergraben und auch unsere
entschlossenheit denn es ist einfacher
für den kreml einzelne staaten zu mobben
und unter druck zu setzen statt die
transatlantische gemeinschaft als ganzes
auf der anderen seite des atlantiks kann
man das aufatmen der europäer hören über
ein amerika das versucht zur alten
ordnung zurückzukehren
zuhören aber auch warnungen vor falschen
illusionen das wird nicht immer
interessen gleichheit sein ich mache mir
darüber keine illusionen da muss man
auch offen über die differenzen sprechen
aber von grundansatz von der wertebasis
von der überzeugung von der demokratie
und ihre handlungsfähigkeit haben wir
ein breites gutes gemeinsames fundament
nach vier jahren entfremdung rücken eu
und usa wieder zusammen ein
transatlantischer schulterschluss trotz
erzwungener räumlicher distanz und jetzt
nochmal strich drunter mit unseren
korrespondenten in brüssel und
washington wir beginnen in washington
mit el mati wissen immer was ist das
wichtigste signal dass joe biden mit
dieser rede senden wollte ja america ist
beck amerika ist zurück ist natürlich
nicht das signal dass alles so ist wie
früher dass sich die anderen
zurücklehnen können amerika wird es am
ende schon richten wenn es darauf
ankommt joe biden sieht eben die
auseinandersetzung zwischen autokratien
und demokratien in dieser welt und sagt
ganz klar werte sind nicht verhandelbar
non transaction sagt er
damit meint er keine deals bei denen man
sich abhängig macht von anderen ich
glaube das ist ein kleine anspielung auf
nord stream zwei das geschäft mit
russland aber auch die geschäfte mit
china in sachen mobilfunk netze und der
wichtigste satz den hat er dann
gesprochen er hat gesagt die demokratien
müssen beweisen dass sie immer noch
liefern können für ihre bevölkerung und
das heißt dass die demokratien gemeinsam
zeigen müssen dass sie mit den
herausforderungen in der welt besser
zurecht kommen als die autoritären
systeme und dabei nicht selber zu
autoritären maßnahmen greifen das ist
der maßstab den legt die usa jetzt
jemanden die länder der welt auch an die
verbündeten an aber das gilt natürlich
für amerika genauso joe biden muss
liefern ihr in den usa in den krisen nur
wenn er das tut dann ist amerika
wirklich zurück als führungsmacht in der
welt und anne gellinek beobachtet die
beiden räder aus europäischer sicht alle
nach den tramp jahren dürfte die eu ja
zunächst mal einige steine vom herzen
gefallen sein
besteht denn jetzt die gefahr dass die
europäer sich wieder zurücklehnen und
sagen die usa sollen es regeln
also aus europäischer sicht war das
schon eine maximale kuschelkurs rede die
joe biden hier auf den ersten blick
gehalten hat er hat alles gesagt was die
europäer gerne hören wollten er hat sich
für die nato-aktion nato bekannt zum
klimaschutz er hat sich ausgesprochen
für internationale zusammenarbeit und
diplomatie und er hat ein paar punkte
vor denen die europäer angst hatten
nicht erwähnt nämlich die zu geringen
verteidigungsausgaben die umstrittene
gaspipeline nord stream und die
strafzölle auf europäische waren
allerdings sollten sich die europäer
hier nicht in sicherheit wiegen denn er
hat der größte teil seiner rede ging
eben über china das sollte die europäer
durchaus nervös machen
martina sehr hart kritisiert er hat
gesagt chinesische unternehmen spielten
nicht nach den regeln und europa
aufgefordert gemeinsam zu handeln und
hier trifft er einen wunden punkt die eu
hat noch keine strategie wie sie sich in
dem dreieck china amerika positionieren
soll
und das könnte der nächste konflikt sein
der heraufzieht die eu muss jetzt eine
eine position finden mit oder gegen den
freundlichen joe biden
vielen dank nach brüssel und nach
washington
und auch in den usa selbst steht
präsident biden vor enormen
herausforderungen dazu gehört gerade
auch ein extremer wintereinbruch
besonders hart trifft er den bundesstaat
texas
bei temperaturen von bis zu minus 15
grad waren dort zeitweise millionen
haushalte ohne strom und damit auch ohne
heizung und auch die wasserversorgung
fiel an vielen orten aus mittlerweile
bessert sich die lage etwas für empörung
sorgt derweil eine urlaubsreise des
republikanischen senators ted cruz nach
mexiko die er inzwischen als fehler
bezeichnete der live blick zum mars
gestern millionen menschen auf der
ganzen welt haben mitgefiebert setzt das
raumfahrzeug dort ohne probleme auf wird
es erste bilder geben
es ist alles gut gegangen jetzt kann die
arbeit so richtig losgehen da oben und
auf der erde
sylvia bleßmann
jubel im kalifornischen pasadena sie
haben es wieder geschafft und ihren fünf
nova erfolgreich auf dem mars gelandet
der beweis ein erstes bild abgesetzt elf
minuten zuvor
denn so lange braucht das signal zur
erde für die aktuelle distanz von 205
millionen kilometern
zu sehen ist der schatten des rovers
kurz vor der landung und etwa zehn
zentimeter große steine auch im berliner
institut für planetenforschung freude
über die geglückte landung in den sieben
heiklen lande minuten zuvor waren die
nerven aller zum zerreißen gespannt
die letzten sekunden sind unheimlich
spannend gerade auch dieses manöver an
der skytrain den rover langsam an den
seilen ab lässt das ist schon auch enorm
und die erleichterung war groß als er
dann wirklich auf dem boden angekommen
großer dank an das gesamte nasa team in
amerika für die tolle leistung und ein
blick in die zukunft
dies ist auch ein schritt auf unserem
weg am ende menschen zum mars zu bringen
und es ist ein sehr wichtiger schritt
dahin
jetzt werden auf dem mars aber erstmal
die systeme des rovers gecheckt in drei
tagen könnte es dann erste farbe davon
roten planeten geben
ihr rückzug von den royalen pflichten im
vergangenen märz war ein schock für
viele fans von prinz harry und seiner
frau merkel jetzt kommt es noch dicker
die beiden werden nie mehr zu ihren
pflichten im britischen königshaus
zurückkehren es gab der buckingham
palast heute bekannt damit muss das paar
seine schirmherrschaften niederlegen und
harry verliert seine militärischen ihren
titel
der schritt soll endgültig sein märgen
und harry leben inzwischen in den usa
und erwarten ihr zweites kind
und dann ist über in der sendung bei dir
genau ich habe zweimal wintersport
alexander schmid peilt einen podestplatz
an als dritter nach dem ersten lauf beim
riesenslalom in cortina d'ampezzo
doch dann der patzer kein happy end und
doch keine zweite deutsche medaille in
der wm geschichte des riesentorlaufs mit
vollem risiko geht alexander schmid in
den zweiten durchgang bei der ersten
zwischenzeit nur eine hundertstel
sekunde zurück
der hang mit etlichen eisplatten
türkisch bei diesem tor kommt schmid zu
spät rutscht weg aus der traum von einer
wm medaille im riesenslalom natürlich
sein so einfach gewesen
gleich nach der wende unter head man
muss nach vorne schauen muss ich
mitnehmen wir bei den nächsten rennen
angreifen
dem favoriten und führende nach dem
ersten durchgang alexei petuchow geht es
ähnlich auch der franzose scheidet im
zweiten lauf aus und so wird
überraschend dessen landsmann mathieu
faivre weltmeister vor luca die
aliprandi nie aus italien links und dem
österreicher markus schwarz gelungene
wm-generalprobe für skispringer karl
geiger platz drei beim weltcup in rasen
noch rumänien allerdings durch die
disqualifikation des norwegers gerückt
ein kurioses skispringen endet für den
vermeintlich vierten karl geiger doch
noch mit einem happy end auf dem podest
das war jetzt wichtig und also da freue
mich darüber dass das ist mir egal ob
echt oder nicht das ist super was war
passiert nach seinem zweiten sprung
wurde der norweger grüne riet zunächst
als sieger gefeiert dann aber wegen
seines zu grossen anzugs nachträglich
disqualifiziert wie zuvor auch schon
skisprung weltmeister markus
eisenbichler und so sprang karl geiger
in einem maßgeschneiderten jazz doch
noch aufs treppchen in die vermutliche
angenehme gesellschaft des japanischen
sieger trio kobayashi und des
zweitplatzierten polen kamil stoch und
morgen den ganzen tag wintersport im zdf
vor uns darauf christian dankeschön für
die meisten gute aussichten beim wetter
da können wir uns wirklich auch darauf
rollen und zwar auf katja horneffer
gleich nach und dann das heute journal
mit dem kollegen claus kleber um 22 uhr
von uns allen hier danke für ihr
interesse auch heute und jetzt wünsche
ich ihnen erst mal einen angenehmen
abend tschüss
[Musik]
können meine damen und herren diesen
kontinent kennen sie das ist afrika und
gut zu erkennen sind auch die
kapverdischen inseln was sie außerdem
noch sehen ist saharastaub der wird hier
weit auf den atlantik hinaus getrieben
aber er nimmt auch die kurve richtung
nordosten und wird uns am wochenende mit
sicherheit aber anfang nächster woche
auch hier in deutschland betreffen
der bringt dann einen milchigen himmel
und vielleicht auch schöne sonnenauf und
sonnenuntergang in dieser nacht ist
davon noch nichts zu merken von der
sahara staub da ist es meist klar oder
nur locker bewölkt es bildet sich zum
teil nebel
wenn die straßen feucht glitzert dann
sollten sie sich auf gefährliche
auswärtige fast machen zumindest im
osten sinken die temperaturen nämlich
nochmal auf plus 2 bis minus 4 grad im
westen bleibt es bei 8 bis 4 grad milder
und morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
im nordosten bei 9 bis 12 grad sonst
wird es frühlingshaft mild bei 13 bis 19
grad und hier nördlich der eifel kann es
vielleicht sogar noch ein oder zwei grad
mehr geben mit eifel fühlen der wind
gibt es her es ist ein südwind so
scheint häufig die sonne
im nordosten sind die wolken etwas
dichter aber am sonntag kommt auch dort
die sonne zum vorschein
und wenn kein nebel stört dann liegen
die temperaturen bei 14 bis 20 grad